Hello and
welcome. It's July 17, 2023.
We're here in Active Inference math
stream number 5.1 with Chris Bodner
on topological deep learning graphs,
complexes, and sheaves. So thank you for
joining, Chris. Looking forward to your
presentation and discussion.
Yeah, thanks so for having me. So,
yeah, as I was just saying, this is my
PhD thesis, which I finished a couple of
months ago. It's also kind of public
online. So if you want to go into the
details, just kind of look this up on
the Internet and you should be able to
find it easily. Obviously, there's lots
of stuff in there. So I kind of try to
give an overview today and maybe also go
in a little bit more detail in certain
aspects since there's not a lot of time
to go through. Yeah,
now I'm Microsoft Research, so this is
basically all work that I did in the
past and when I was at University of
Cambridge. All right, so let's get
started. Right, so let's
start very easily. Now, I'm actually not
sure exactly what's kind of the
background of the people who are
watching, but in machine learning
there's all these kind of subfield that
emerged a few years ago which is called
geometric deep learning, which is
essentially looking at how to apply
these kind of deep learning. Neural
network architectures on data, living on
all sorts of structures
or geometries or spaces if you want.
And this has a lot of application,
especially in the life sciences. And
there's kind of been a lot of instances
of this in kind of very famous
publications, some of which you see
here. But just to give some examples,
for instance, if you have proteins or
molecules or things like that, they
usually represented as graphs. And you
kind of have some data living on these
graphs, like kind of the properties of
certain atoms and so on. So these
kind of things and so far, these kind
of spaces or these kind of problems,
learning problems, if you want, they
have been approached mostly kind of with
a geometrical mindset, as the kind of
name of this subfield also mentions.
But something that I would argue
is that geometry is not everything that
you need and there's kind of other non
geometrical aspects when you are in such
a setting. And this is kind of
quite obvious once you realize that the
spaces that kind of show up in the field
and in many applications, they are very
heterogeneous. So, as I mentioned, for
instance, you could have graphs that
could represent anything. In this case,
it's the caffeine molecule that you see
here on the left. And you want to have
some models that predict certain
properties of this molecule and so on.
But for instance, you can have grids.
And we see grids all the time and data
living on grids. And I'm referring to
images, videos, they are all kind of
pixels living on a grid. And then you
can have more sophisticated things. You
could have some meshes, for instance.
They're all over in computer graphics
and then you could have some sort of
manifold. So for instance, if you're
doing maybe weather modeling or
something, we live on a sphere,
topologically speaking. So you might
want to model your data as living on a
sphere and so on.
But nonetheless, even if these spaces
are kind of geometrically, kind of
heterogeneous, and some of them don't
even have a geometrical structure in
kind of a strict mathematical sense,
they all have what's called a
topological structure, which is kind of
like kind of a weaker kind of structure,
but it's kind of more general. And I'm
going to talk a bit in a few seconds
about what that means by in general.
When you do kind of mathematical
physics, you kind of have a ladder of
structures where you kind of keep
building on top and the more structure
you have, the more sophisticated things
you can do and so on. And kind of at the
base of this diagram just have sets,
just kind of a collection of elements
with no kind of extra structure and then
you kind of keep going up in this ladder
and you add stuff on top of sets and
so on. And as I was saying, kind of most
of the work is kind of focused on maybe
the top levels of this hierarchy, but
it's kind of topological level, which
are kind of the weakest kind of level
you can add on top of sets has kind of
been neglected to a large extent. And
part of what I've been doing in my PhD
thesis was essentially looking at these
kind of learning problems on these kind
of spaces from a more topological
perspective and kind of try to fill in
these blanks. So this is kind of the
overview, okay, so if we are to
adopt this topological perspective,
what would that actually mean or how
would that look like? I guess it could
look in different ways, but in what I've
done, in my cases, it looks kind of like
this. So we have horizontally,
we kind of have a space that could be
anything. This is just kind of an
abstract space. It could be a grid or
things like we've seen in the previous
example and kind of vertically attached
to the regions of this space. We have
data. So data is kind of this vertical
component and you kind of see these
flags kind of being kind of anchored in
these regions. So that kind of signifies
you have some data that's kind of
associated with that region. So that's
kind of the high level perspective and
I'm going to make that a bit more
concrete a bit later. And there's
kind of two essential things about this
picture. A first thing is locality.
So the data is attached to
some regions of this space, this
topological space, and in that sense
it's local, so it's kind of associated
with the region. And maybe to give a
concrete example, if you kind of have a
temperature sensor somewhere in space,
right, you could think of whatever that
sensor is measuring is kind of a
property of kind of the immediate
surrounding around that sensor.
So it's kind of describing some property
of a region in space. So that'll be kind
of a concrete example. And another kind
of axiom that we're starting with is
that the space has structure.
So the space has kind of, it's kind of
made up of various regions and these
regions intersect in various ways and
that implicitly also makes our data
structured because the data is attached
to these regions. So there is kind of
some structure in the data.
All right, so that's kind of the picture
and actually many of these things relate
to category theory. I'm not going to go
in depth into this because it's kind of
sophisticated and I'm not an expert
myself in category theory, but kind of
the high level here is that category
theory is kind of a nice way. To
translate between different structure in
mathematics and kind of discuss about
properties of certain kinds of objects
and translate that to some different
kinds of objects and find all these kind
of relations and connections. And a
concrete example is, for instance, if
you want to study some manifolds, some
surfaces, you could associate some
groups to these surfaces and then any
sorts of relations between these kind of
surfaces, also translating some
relations about these groups or some
other algebraic structures. So you could
study these manifolds by doing algebra
instead of doing geometry or topology or
something else. So also in this case,
it's kind of manifesting the fact that
we kind of translate these from spaces
to data. So kind of because we associate
the regions in a space, certain kinds of
data, this is kind of how this
translation manifests in what I've just
described in the previous picture. So
you could think of this as some sort of
translation or mapping from spaces and
regions in that space to kind of data
attached to that space. But yeah, I'm
not going to go in a lot of detail into
this, but just kind of to keep in the
back of your mind that there's this
stuff lurking in the background. All
right, so I promise this is the only
math definition I'm giving in this talk
and then I'll stop. But just because I'm
mentioning topological spaces quite
often, I just wanted to kind of give
this axiomatic definition, which might
sound sophisticated, but I have a
picture at the end and hopefully it'll
be clear what is it.
So it's just a set. As I was saying, we
start with sets and we put stuff on top,
right? So you start with a set and then
you also have a collection of subsets of
this set called the open sets that need
to satisfy certain axioms. So you could
think of these open sets as kind of
regions of this space, very informally
speaking. So something that kind
of has to be satisfied is that, well,
the empty set and the set itself need
to be open set. So in some sense, you
could think of this as saying the set
itself is a region of that space very
informally, which it's kind of,
let's say, obvious. And then there's
some kind of constraints about
intersecting and taking units of this
region. So if we take the intersection
of two regions, we should get another
one of these regions. And if we take a
union of these regions, we should get
another region. And there are some
constraints again, like, okay, how big
these intersections should be. There
should be finite intersections, but you
could have infinite unions. But that's a
technicality and we can just skip
anyways. But to see a picture so on the
left, you just see the set x itself.
And here I've put like a potential
neighborhood structure or kind of like
open set structure on this space. So we
have an open set U, another open set V.
By this axiom, their intersection should
also be an open set. So you see this
intersection in the middle being another
open set, and then the set itself is
another open set. So it's just kind of
splitting stuff into regions, kind of.
You could think of it like that. All
right, so this is a topological space,
and now let's add data, right? So we
mentioned that we have data and then we
have a space, and then we add data on
top. So so far we've seen how a
topological space looks like. Now let's
add this kind of vertical stuff, these
flags that you saw before. We just put
some data on top of these regions. And
if we put data on all the regions of the
space, on all the open sets, we get
these structures that
in categories here, like in algebraic
topology, also geometry, they are called
presheaves, which sounds very fancy,
but all is just kind of a definition of
what I was already describing.
Essentially, you have some data for each
region. For instance, for region
U, you have this f of U, which is kind
of the data attached to region U. So you
could think of f of U, some set with
describing the data that lives there in
that region. But there's also an extra
thing. You have some sort of maps going
between these kind of pieces of data,
and these are called restriction maps.
And why is that? They provide you a way
to kind of zoom in if you want,
right? Like you have the data attached
to the whole set x, and then you could
think, okay, how do I take this data?
How do I go from this data to data on a
smaller region on x? So it's kind of a
way to zoom in on that data,
essentially. And I'm going to show some
example in a second. So these are called
pre sheaves. And just to see an example,
our space here is kind of one of the
simplest kind of space you could think
of. It's just 1D or horizontal line,
right? Just the real line. And then you
have some regions which are just given
by open intervals on
the real line. And then some pieces of
data could be functions like continuous
functions on those regions. So here's
some sample data on this first interval.
Here's another function on the second
interval. Here's some data on this third
interval. And actually in this case, it
happens that all these functions agree
on the overlap. So where these regions
overlap, they take the same values and
we can actually glue them together in a
single function over the entire region.
So this is just an example of a
preshief and it's called the preshift of
continuous functions. So our data in
this case is continuous functions and
the space is just the realign and we put
these functions on top of the realign.
But it turns out because of this kind of
special property, that we can kind of
glue data and we uniquely get some other
piece of data, right? We can take these
three pieces. It's just exactly like a
puzzle, right? We put these things
together and we get a fourth thing,
which is kind of a single function where
we just overlap these functions, right?
And these presheaves
that satisfy these kind of properties
where you can kind of glue them to get a
unique piece of data. They are called
sheaves and basically the preshave
of continuous functions is actually a
sheep. So this is kind of a way to
formalize data attached to these things.
It's going to get less technical in a
second. So just to give more examples.
So for instance, in this way we could
describe data on a sphere. And let's say
if this data is just some vector field
on a sphere. So let's say if this is
Earth, right, this could be some wind
vector field, right? Like if we do
weather modeling or something, you just
have a vector field describing the wind
on the surface of Earth, right? And you
might want to do some machine learning
on top of this, where this kind of
vector field has a sheet structure, and
you could think of it as a sheath,
because if you have some vector field on
the red region, a vector field on the
yellow region, I can kind of glue them
together uniquely if they overlap. If
they agree on the overlap and we get the
vector field on this bigger region. But
something that's quite nice is that even
if we have a very different kind of
space namely a graph which is very
different from a sphere in all points of
view, we can still apply the exact same
kind of axioms and terminology and kind
of definitions and we can have a sheath
of our graph. So in this way we could
have, for instance, some features
associated to the nodes of the graph,
some features associated with the edges
of the graph, and there's another node
which has its own features and this is
actually the exact same thing we have in
graph machine learning. So this is quite
nice. What this kind of topological
perspective allows us to do is we kind
of have a unified way of thinking, if
you want, about very kind of
heterogeneous spaces and we can model on
all of them data attached to them by
using this kind of sheet terminology and
other ways as well. But I'm not going
into that in this talk. All right, so
this is kind of an overview of what I've
been doing in my thesis. And just
to kind of dive a bit deeper into this,
I just wanted to go into one paper that
we did at Europe last year. Yeah. So
this was last year on what's
called shift diffusion. So essentially,
how can we use what I've just described
to do some useful stuff when doing
machine learning on graphs, all right?
And this was a collaboration with
Francesco de Giovanni ben Chamberlain
pietro Leo, my advisor and Michael
Bronstein. Okay? So before I dive into
this, I just want to give some
background in case people are not
familiar with this. So the kind of
favorite architecture of people doing
machine learning on graphs these days
are these things called graph neural
networks, which are actually very simple
kind of models. So in the setting
you have some features. So each node in
your graph will have some features.
This is what this h vector
here denotes. So it's the vector
h associated with node A at layer or
time t, whatever. So you have some
features for each of these nodes and
what you're doing each of if you're at a
certain node, you want to kind of
compute a new representation or new
features for this node at the next
layer. So essentially are learning
representations and what the graph
neural networks are doing. This node
will receive a message from all the
other nodes that are neighbors
with this node. And this message
can also be passed, can use some neural
networks in there, but essentially it's
some processing of these features of the
neighbors and these are aggregated into
this message. So here in Green and
then this is passed through some update
function that combines the message from
the neighbors with the old
representation of this node and it gives
you a new representation at the next
layer. And this happens for all the
nodes, right? So then you get some new
representations for this node and this
is one layer and then you kind of keep
repeating this for as many layers as you
like. So this is kind of how you do deep
learning on graphs. It's kind of a very
simple recipe and most models
actually vary in the way they kind of
compute these messages and in the way
this update function is designed. But
that's kind of the parameters most of
these models use. Otherwise they all
kind of respect this framework and work
in this kind of particular way. And to
give you maybe an example for why you
would want to do this, you might want to
do node classification. This is kind of
a classic problem in graph machine
learning. There are others, but I'm just
going to talk about this because it's
easier. So you have a graph and
this graph has nodes that have different
labels. Here there's just two kinds of
labels, this orange and blue.
And you have some edges between these
nodes. And what you want is you want to
do this kind of message passing that I
was describing to compute some
representations for these nodes where
you can easily classify the blue and
orange nodes. Now something that's
quite interesting is that for many kind
of graph neural networks, depending on
the properties of these graphs and how
these kind of different nodes are
connected, their performance might vary
quite a lot. So in particular they're
affected by this property called
heterophili. So this is kind of a
measure of how much opposites attractive
you want, right? So it has a very simple
formula. Basically you take the number
of edges between orange and blue nodes
and you divide by the total number of
edges, right? So basically you kind of
check how many connections we have in
this graph between things that are quite
opposite to each other versus
connections that are between similar
kind of nodes. So if you have a lot
of these kind of heterogeneous
connections, then you have very high
heterophili. And it turns out that many
graphene networks actually struggle in
that setting. It's very hard to classify
things in that setting. And intuitively
you could kind of also figure out why
because you could easily apply some kind
of reasoning where oh, this node
looks a lot like this other node is
connected to. So they kind of must be in
the same community if you want or in the
same label. But it's much harder to do
that when all things are kind of
different from each other and
these communities kind of don't form
right, even visually. If you see a graph
and it has some nicely clustered
communities, it's quite easy to draw a
line between those and say, oh, this is
a community, is another community. But
if things are very mixed, then it's
quite challenging. And it turns out it's
also challenging for these models, not
just for kind of our intuition when we
would have to do this. So this is kind
of some problem where this topological
perspective I was mentioning will be
used to do some useful stuff.
Okay? So coming back to Sheaves on
graphs. And at this point I think you
can largely forget what I mentioned in
the introduction or if there's something
you misunderstood there. We kind of
start from zero bit here, so there's no
problem. So on the left you just have
a graph which is kind of the incidence
structure of a graph. I just drawn here
the simplest possible graph that has two
nodes v and U. And then there's an edge
between them. So this is just a graph
with one edge. That's all that's going
on here. And I've just represented it by
kind of in this kind of incidence
structure kind of way, right? Node v is
incident to node e and node u, sorry,
edge e and node U is incident to edge e.
So this is just an incident structure
and what this kind of triangle symbol is
showing is just this incident structure.
It's just a way to symbolize this
incidence relation if you want. Okay,
so this is just a graph, right? And a
way we can kind of think of field zone
graphs is just mapping this graph
structure. So this is kind of this
categorical theory translation. We
translate this graph into something else
which looks very similar. The structure
is kind of the same, it's just kind of
the meaning of these things change. So
for each node v we have here,
this will be a vector space. So F of v
is a vector space. For each node u we
have F of U which is another vector
space. For each edge e we have this Fe
which is another vector space. So all
nodes have their own vector spaces and
the features associated to those nodes
leaving those vector spaces. So
basically for each node we have a vector
space of features that's all that's
going on so far. And also these arrows
that these incidence relations also
translate into something and they
translate into the obvious thing linear
maps. So if these are vector spaces,
then these things should be linear maps
or just some matrices essentially,
right? So for each arrow you see here we
have a matrix and
something that I'll argue and
show in a few slides is that basically
message passing is
very similar on graphs, is very similar
with group actions in group theory.
So let me explain exactly why. So we
kind of can think of what we have on the
left these arrows from the incidence
relation. We could think of these arrows
as kind of some buttons we can press.
So what do I mean by that? So if we have
this node v on the left, right, and this
e, now if we have some features, some
feature living in FOV, right,
we could just kind of press this arrow
button here and then if we multiply
this matrix by this feature, we will get
an edge feature. So it's kind of like if
you go along this arrow, this matrix
will multiply this feature and this
vertex feature and it will give you an
edge feature. So you could think of
these arrows as kind of giving you some
sort of actions that you can play with
to move features from vertex to edge and
edge to vertex. So in this case it's
kind of a left action, right? So this is
what I'm saying. I'm taking this arrow,
which is this one here, and I act on
some features of node v. So this HOV
that lives here and how I do that
is I just take this matrix, this matrix
associated with this arrow, and I
multiply this vector HOV. So just
matrix times vector, that's all. And
then we get an edge feature. So this is
just kind of a way to move from here to
here. So this already kind of looks a
bit like message passing, right? We're
kind of passing a message from this
vertex to this edge, but now we also
need to pass a message from this edge to
these other vertex U. So we need to get
from V to U and we did that by passing
through e. So by doing that, we could do
that by kind of going in reverse. So we
could have a right action where instead
of applying this matrix, we applied
adjoint matrix. So that's just a
transpose matrix. So if we want to go
from here to here, instead of applying
this matrix, we apply it transpose
because we want to go the other way
around. If we compose
these things, then we can move features
from V to U. So this is just a way that
kind of we can apply these actions to
do message passing and these are called
shift actions or preshift actions. And
I'm going to now show what's kind of the
relation between this and what we have
in group theory.
So one way to represent a group
is by kind of having some sort of graph,
like here on the left. So we
kind of have some star object, it's just
kind of a dummy thing there. But all the
group structure is in these arrows,
right? So for each group element. So
let's say this g is a 90 degree
rotation, for instance. Let's say we do
have a group of rotations, just to have
some concrete example.
So this arrow could correspond to a 90
degree rotation. We have another arrow
that does the opposite, minus kind of 90
degree rotation. That's the inverse of
that transformation. So this is kind of
the structure of this group. And if we
have, we also do this similar kind of
translation as we've just seen. So
basically we define a preshift on this
group. We map this star to a vector
space. So the star kind of replaces the
vertex we had before. Now we just have a
single vertex and it's just these arrows
we have. So the star is mapped, this
vector space that you show here in blue,
right? And now, if we actually do group
actions, which are kind of a very well
established concept in group theory,
well, for instance, if you want to act
on this vertex sorry, not vertex on this
vector. V right here. You have a vector
in this vector space, and you want to
act on it by this group transformation
g. So, essentially, you want to press
this arrow. So you apply some action on
it. Then what you do is well,
because of this translation, this g has
been mapped to some matrix, which is the
rotation matrix, the corresponding
rotation matrix, and you apply this
rotation matrix on v and you get like a
90 degree rotation here. So this is
what's going on. This kind of vertical
vector is showing the rotated vector.
So this is completely analogous with
what we've seen on the previous slide.
This is how kind of sheaves connect
these kind of actions. So essentially
what you could think of as message
passing is same as group actions in
group theory, but you just replace this
group with a graph. So it's kind of
analogous to that, right? So it's just
kind of a different kind of translations
where we replace the object on the left.
Now it looks like this is a graph, this
is a group, right? But kind of the rest
stays exactly the same. And this kind of
gives us a way to formalize in a way by
looking in this topological perspective
to connect all these kind of symmetries
and things like that that have been
explored quite a lot in machine learning
to message passing on graphs and to see
one way in which they are related.
Okay, so now you might say, okay, this
was all very sophisticated and nice,
but you know, what, is this going
anywhere, basically? And I'm just going
to show you kind of a very short
example. There's more, but the time is
limited. And something we showed is
that, as I was saying in the beginning,
many graph neural networks kind of
struggle in these heterophilic graphs.
And what we showed is that no matter how
heterophilic or kind of weird your graph
is, you can always kind of find some
shift structure, essentially kind of a
message passing neural network, that if
you use sufficient layers, it will be
able to disentangle the classes of the
nodes, right? So just to show you in
this picture what you have here on the
very far left, the colors of the nodes,
they show the class. So there's three
colors here. So three classes, right?
And this is kind of the graph in the
beginning and the position of the nodes
in this box denotes the features. So
that's a way to kind of just to
visualize the features.
The 2D position is actually the 2D
feature vector of each node. And you can
see in the beginning, everything is kind
of super messy and entangled, right?
Like if you want to classify these
nodes, it's kind of very hard because
their representations, their initial
representations are very messy and kind
of intertwined. But as we stack more
layers of a particular kind of sheath or
a message passing model, you see how
progressively these classes get kind of
more disentangled and more disentangled
at each new layer. So these
representations kind of collapse and
they form these kind of clusterings,
right? And then when you get with
something like at the end, you can kind
of see these three communities very
clearly and it's extremely easy to
separate. And kind of the essence behind
these results was we showed for
different kinds of problems what sorts
of chief or message passing models you
need by using this theory to solve kind
of problems. And this is quite important
because it kind of shows you some
important bits and pieces in the
architecture that you might want to kind
of change or use in order to solve
certain kinds of problems. And we also
had some sort of impossibility resolved.
So if you use a graph neural network of
some kind, you can't solve this problem
or you'll struggle to solve this
problem. And we also saw, okay, if you
use some more general ones, then you
might have a chance. So this is kind of
some high level view behind this
theoretical stuff. And what we actually
do in practice is to
essentially learn these message passing
functions or to learn the sheath or
these matrices. So in practice, like
when someone gives you a node
classification task, it's very hard to
know beforehand what exactly is
the right sheep or the right message
passing model to solve that task.
And what we do essentially, we learn
that from data. So we learn these
matrices that do the message passing.
We learn them from data by using
some neural networks which are shown
here in red. And then you learn how to
kind of transfer features between these
vector spaces and kind of move them
around. So this is just showing how
these vectors, which are features of
these nodes and edges, how they're kind
of moved around by kind of going through
via these matrices, just some matrix
multiplications. Okay,
so that's kind of the high level view
behind this model. And we evaluated this
on some kind of real world heterophilic
data sets where you
have to classify nodes based on kind of
various communities or different kinds
of labels. And these data sets going
from right to left, they are getting
more heterophilic. So in some sense more
challenging for classic architectures.
And our models, which are kind of
inspired by all this stuff that I
mentioned, they score quite highly in
these benchmarks. And at the same time,
they also revealed some or justified
some various choices that other models
in this space have done. But maybe they
were not so well justified, or maybe
they had different kind of motivations.
We also managed to kind of show why
various things they were already doing,
why they made sense from the point of
view of this kind of theory.
All right, well, that's all I had.
Yeah, thanks for listening and yeah,
happy to chat more about this and also
have lots of backup slides in case,
depending on how far we venture off with
this question.
Cool. Well, awesome work. Thank you for
the presentation. For people who are in
the live chat, they can write some
questions, but there's many things I
think we could talk about. So I want to
start with reading a quote from an
abstract of the paper by von
der Laur, Kudal and DeVries just to kind
of ground this in the active inference
context and really justify why the
message passing approaches that you are
describing are helping in the active
inference modeling. It's two papers.
It's called Realizing Synthetic Active
Inference Agents and they wrote, with a
full message passing account of
synthetic active inference agents, it
becomes possible to derive and reuse
message updates across models and move
closer to industrial applications of
synthetic active inference framework.
So how does knowing the message passing
structure help reuse a model across
different settings or facilitate the
legibility of the model?
Right? So first of all, I'm not super
familiar with the kind of active
inference literature, so you'll have
to help me there a bit to anchor
maybe the discussions a bit more into
that. But I think if I understand
correctly, the kind of question you're
getting at is basically how can kind of
message passing help us generalize in
kind of various kinds of settings or
maybe from one graph to another and
things like that? And this is a kind
of active area of research, how exactly
digitalization is happening. But
something you could notice, for
instance, something that for instance,
was shown like these models are quite
good at, for instance, plotting patterns
or structures depending on how exactly
you implement them. But for instance,
let's say you have a triangle in your
graph or that'll be kind of the simplest
structure, right? You have a triangle or
some other kind of kind of gadget in
your graph, like particular subgraphs
that might show up in different kinds of
various graphs. The graphs themselves
might look completely different from
each other, but these kind of patterns
might kind of be reemerging in multiple
like local patterns might reemerge in
multiple graphs and that could help you
a way to kind of generalize, right?
Like you could see, for instance, if you
have clicks, they're super important in
kind of when you do social network
modeling and things like that because
they kind of show this kind of close
group of friends, right? They all talk
to each other, so they kind of form a
click like everyone's connected to each
other, right? And then you might be able
to use that engine like another
completely different social context
where these agents are again kind of
communicating in a similar manner or are
connected in a similar manner, even if
the kind of overall pattern is quite
different. And it goes way beyond just
kind of structural similarities because
there's also features in there. So
there's combinations of kind of
structural patterns and features that
give you even more complicated patterns,
right? Like you might have a triangle,
but then also two of the features in
this triangle look in a certain way and
one that looks in another way. So that
gives you even more kind of refinement
and even kind of richer pattern
detection abilities. So you have
essentially this ability to kind of spot
patterns at multiple scales as well. So
you could see this happening at multiple
scales. You could have patterns of
patterns, right? You could have entire
communities connected in various
patterns and so on. And again, it's kind
of also a research question. How do you
capture these hierarchical patterns and
so on. In general, you have to do more
message passing if you want to capture
things that are further away from each
other because otherwise they can't talk
to each other, right? So, yeah, I don't
know if that actually answered your
question or if I was kind of going in
the right direction there. It's great.
It brings up a lot of different cool
ideas like this patterns all the way
down, but totally agree. I think we can
now perhaps explore some more specific
connections to active inference because
hopefully the listenership or viewership
of this, it's kind of like a two way
street. Like some people may be coming
from more of your background and then
learning about active inference and
generative models as a specific system
of interest for The First time. But
also, certainly for A lot of people in
the active inference space, these
methods coming from category theory have
only recently come up to,
I guess, more prominence in Bayesian
modeling, at least where we are. So it's
a cool connection to make. I think one
of the biggest touch points off the bat
was, like you mentioned, multiplying a
matrix by a vector and interpreting that
as an edge. So just in the inference
part of the generative model about
sensory observations, we always talk
about the thermometer observation and
then the underlying hidden state
temperature. So that exactly describes
that case. And that's why we
can represent the active inference
generative models, the perceptual parts
and the action parts in terms of matrix
multiplication. It's why the MATLAB code
for generative models does look mostly
like matrix multiplication and it can
all be done explicitly that way.
Are there models that don't have this
feature? Or what do we gain by
having all of our edges defined as
appreciative action with a matrix and a
vector in this setting of agent
generative models with perception and
action? Any thoughts on that?
Yeah, I think essentially kind of the
graph structure is kind of telling you
these things interact in some way,
right? So there's some communication
between these vertices if we're kind of
in a crash setting, right, and then kind
of what the sheath is giving you or any
message passing model essentially is
expressing a way in which way that
connection should manifest in the model
or in what way that connection should be
used to process information. So in this
case I was mentioning, okay, you have
linear maps because you could go on the
type if your type of data are vector
spaces, then this transformation will be
some sort of linear maps. But it doesn't
necessarily have to be. So for instance,
it could go to any nonlinear
transformation, right? And this is
what's happening in general. In
practice, if you have a neighbor, the
message coming from that neighbor could
be modulated by any sort of
transformation you want. So it could be
linear, it could be nonlinear, it could
be something, I don't know,
you can specify it basically. But
essentially you could think of this as
you have a structure level telling you
who should communicate to whom. And then
you kind of have some semantics that
this kind of shift is adding on top
saying how should these things
communicate? Right? Like the first thing
is who should communicate or what should
communicate. And then the semantics we
add on top essentially describe how
should that communication manifest.
Essentially.
Very cool. I think that maps exactly to
how we talk about the sparsity of
variables in degenerative model. So here
the topology of the nodes in the graph
that we want to do message passing on
are going to be describing the agent and
the environment or the generative model
that includes perception, cognition and
action. So a lot of people have proposed
different sparsity architectures for
integrated modeling of perception,
cognition, action. So one example would
just be like kind of around the clock,
like action influences the environment,
environment influences perception. Back
to cognition, you could add a self loop
using an arkov blanket and different
kinds of connectivities and that defines
the sparsity topologically, which is
where you showed the stack and you were
on the second and the third levels, I
think, of the stack and then what flows
it has to be described,
what that edge does. So what
is that? That is also being provided.
Yeah, exactly. And it could even go to
the extreme where does that edge
actually do anything? So for instance,
if you have a matrix that's just
the zero matrix, for instance,
associated to that edge, it will just
kind of multiply by zero and that gives
you zero and it's kind of essentially
pruning that edge, right? Like I kind of
get rid of it, I don't want that
communication to happen. But there's
also kind of this possibility where
these kind of semantics, they override
the structural level where you say,
okay, I don't need to communicate with
this other agent person or whatever. It
depends on what these rates actually
mean and in what context you are.
And then there's also the case where you
could do some sort of selective pruning
where this matrix depending on
so in kind of linear algebra, the matrix
has a kernel. So it's all the stuff that
that matrix sends to zero. So what
vectors are sent to zero, right? But not
everything will be sent to zero unless
you're the zero matrix. So depending on
the features of the neighbors, you could
also just send some of the neighbors to
zero, right? And that kind of removes
those neighbors from the equation. They
just kind of get they're
not factored in anymore. So you kind of
have this it's a way to get this
parsity, I guess, that you were also
talking about where certain
only maybe a small subset of the inputs
or kind of only subset
of the features are actually kind of
doing some meaningful stuff among the
neighbors and everything else will be
kind of zeroed out. Yeah, that makes me
think of the Lasso regression, which
tries to set most variables of having an
impact of zero so that a few hopefully
important variables really pop out in
the analysis. But also there's newer
techniques, I guess, of attention
modeling and reweighting that isn't just
like, okay, set five of them to one and
then the rest of them to zero. More
nuanced. So I think that sparsity with
the expressivity is basically the
best of both worlds because you do want
to have a situation where there is an
edge, but the attention being paid to it
is zero. So functionally,
that doesn't have an update on the
belief state, even though in principle
the edge exists. And that's why we can
model situations where the agent
believes they have impact in the world.
But actually, just because the edge in
principle exists doesn't mean that it
has any given impact. And so that allows
the articulation of these models where
they factorize and keeps interpretable
motifs in terms of just little clusters
of motifs. Here in
our case describing the action
perception and cognition types of
systems of interest. But people, I
believe, already implicitly do this.
They will often add an adjective and
refer to x kind of active inference. So
like deep active inference with a
temporal horizon, sophisticated active
inference with this kind of nesting.
And those are pointing to a given
feature. But of course, those features,
as we're hoping, should be composable.
And so this seems to be bringing
tools that are even more general than
just action perception modeling because
they're at a lower level of abstraction
than any specific system of interest.
But where this work and kind of timeless
thinking around cybernetic systems come
together through the active inference
generative model as a Bayes graph,
it gets very exciting. Yeah. And maybe
also something worth emphasizing here is
that even if this kind of semantic level
can get rid of some edges, right, by
doing this kind of pruning. Something it
cannot get rid of is the computation.
So something that kind of that
structural graphs level forces you to
do. It kind of tells you what should you
spend compute time on, right? Because
even if you're going to decide to prune
an edge, you still need to decide that
which takes compute time. So you still
need to look at all your neighbors if
you're a node, right, and decide what to
prune. Or maybe you don't prune anything
or whatever, but you have to look at
every edge. And one way to look at this
is the graph structure defines you
a computational graph or kind of a
computational series of computational
steps you have to execute. And then the
kind of the sheet structure or the
message passing model actually specifies
what those steps are and in what
particular way they look. Exactly.
That's one point. And you also mentioned
attention, and actually I'm glad you
did, because this is actually quite
related and in certain ways more general
than attention. And actually, maybe
going back to this slide, it might be a
nice way to see this.
So here basically what happens in
attention. Instead of learning these
matrices that we learn here in
attention, you learn attention
coefficients here. So you just learn a
scalar. That's the attention
coefficient. How much attention should I
pay to essentially this overall edge,
let's say, which will be just a scalar?
What we do is kind of a bit more
complicated because you just learn, how
do I transform these neighbors? So it's
kind of a whole matrix rather than a
single scalar, but there's also some
subtle differences. But in a follow up
work we did, we also combined this with
attention and went a bit more general
and that also worked quite
well. But the kind of underlying idea is
very similar. You want to modulate the
way you transform information based on
the information itself, right? So you
have this kind of one level of
recursivity. If you want that, you are
also alluding to that. It happens in
active inference, where, okay, so if
I'm node v, right, my neighbor knew it
has some features, and based on these
features, which are xu, I'm going to
find out the matrix that will be used to
process xu, right. So it's kind of very
recursive and it's what happens with
attention, right. Based on the features
of node u, I'm going to compute an
attention coefficient that I'm going to
apply to this feature of you, right?
I'm going to decide based on this
feature, how much attention should I pay
to it. And here we decide how should I
process it more generally in a linear
way. So you have this kind of loopiness
structure embedded in there.
Awesome. I'll bring up a few more points
because I think there's so many great
pieces. So Toby St. Clair, Smyth who
we recently discussed his dissertation
in Livestream 54, introduced a term
or at least a phrasing, the
compositional cognitive cartography.
And so thinking about the
compositionality of cognitive systems,
and I think what you're describing here
with this notion that the mappings are
more general than the kind of attention
mechanisms known, famously today, that
those represent, like a lower
dimensional special case of one kind of
architecture. Makes me think about how
the Bayesian graph is kind of semantic
in principle and can have all of these
nice categorical formalisms around them.
And you can even build the connector to
empirical data with the presheaf and the
sheaf, which may be news to even many
empirical researchers doing data
analysis certainly was for me. But the
message passing provides a rigorous
translation from whatever semantic model
is proposed topologically to an
implementation procedure that can
be planned for and executed in linear
time or at least with definable
characteristics. So message passing
plays a really important part in going
from the abstract what is possible, to
the implementations of any of these
actual models. And it does it in a
really general way where is it accurate
to say that we hope that implementation
with message passing compatible
generative models will kind of roll out
better because we won't have some of the
engineering challenges that less
reusable abstractions might carry?
It's hard to say. I think there's also
certainly some limitations to this
paradigm as well. So just kind of doing
this kind of message passing, I think,
as you were mentioning, one thing is
that it kind of scales up quite easily,
like linearly with the size of the
graph, but that also come at a cost. So
there's certain results showing this has
limits in expressivity. So if
you actually want to go beyond this,
for instance, instead of just looking at
pairs of nodes, you have to look at
tuples and these kind of high order
groupings of nodes in order to
kind of get higher explicitity. There's
all sorts of techniques to do that and
there's always this kind of tension
between being more expressive and being
efficient that will always be there in
any sort of algorithm or method.
It's kind of hard to say. We can
definitely say this is kind of not the
optimist solution. Let's say if you want
to do things message passing in itself
but maybe doing some sort of
computations on graphs could
be maybe
also something that's kind of maybe
missing a bit in kind of the graph ML
setting. Is the context where
you assume your graph is known. And you
need to have some graph
structure, at least a sensible way to
construct it. Right. But for many kind
of more I
don't know, how should I phrase
that? I guess for less clearly defined
things like, okay, if I'm an agent doing
perception in the real world or
something, right? If I'm trying to
create a graph of the world,
what's an object, what do I create
a node for? Right? If I want to have one
note or object and there's some
connections between objects and things
like that. I know it's like some wild
example that comes to mind. I don't know
if you actually want to do that but
let's say you want, right? Then there's
also all these kind of blurry things
like what's an object and what's not an
object? What's kind of somewhere in
between maybe is that a node? So it's
kind of like what I'm trying to say,
that the graph structure is kind of very
discreet, right? The node is either
there or it's not there and edges there
is not there. But then the world is kind
of very fuzzy, right? So if you use
graphs as a model for your world then
there probably has to be some decision
to be made somewhere about these kind of
fuzzy concepts. They actually translate
in a concrete graph entity like an
object, an edge or whatever or not based
on some kind of inference procedure.
And I don't know if we do that or not as
kind of humans as intelligent agents,
but that's kind of some interesting
thing to think about. Maybe you could
also well, maybe one way to solve that
is also kind of stuff like soft edges
and things like that. And in some way if
you have attention coefficients, it's a
bit like that. If an edge has a weight
of 0.1 or something, it's almost like
not being there but it's still kind of
there. So it's a bit
of a soft graph architecture.
I guess at the edge level you can
implement this softness but I think it's
a bit harder at kind of the node level,
right? Like how do you kind of model a
node that's kind of there and not there?
Yeah, there's just some random thoughts
that's. Very interesting about the fuzzy
object identification and kind of
similarities and differences between
nodes and edges even though in some ways
they have some similarities too or
interoperabilities too. One other point
of contact was like an underlying hidden
space that we understand topologically
that projects a vector space from
different places so that could be a
vector of thermometer readings and
we want to have a smooth path within the
homeostatic range defined up to a
boundary point. Not saying that that's
the structure of the world but a
structure of a very heuristic and simple
model might be to aim for continuity
and have a defined hidden estate space
that has continuity underneath and is
able to emit vectors. That kind of
brings some of these classifier type
discussions that you brought up and the
kind of fundamental impossibility of
geometric classification because you are
going to end up with gray zones whereas
even if it takes a bitwise description,
you can separate the network. So that
gives an actual completeness measure and
that allows measures like I mean
amount of computational resources or in
a more statistically principled way like
the Bayesian Information criterion. So
how many nodes should we have? We should
be on some trade off front in some
modeling space. I don't know what to
tell you. It's a map, not a territory.
And that's more justifiable. And so even
lifelike organisms might want to self
evidence staying emitting from
a living state. And so that provides a
really simple graphical architecture
to cybernetic systems. And then
active Inference explores a lot of
different more specific motifs within
that broader blanket persistence picture
and the path of least action. So that's
what enables the physics in that space
and why these methods, which as far as I
understand are often used in quantum
mechanics, are being able
to come together with active inference
this way. Yeah,
something that comes to mind when you
mention this, I think there's also like
a recent avenue of research in
this area where people and it's again
kind of generated by the fact that you
don't know the graph beforehand many
times. And I think kind of the old
school approach was, well, you construct
it based on some rules, right? Like
you're going to say, I don't know, some
things are similar, I'm going to put an
edge between them and you define similar
in whatever way you like and so on. And
there was this kind of recent trend
where what you try to do is kind of
latent graph inference, or some people
call it manifold learning, if you think
of the graph as some sort of manifold.
But this kind of very informally
speaking and essentially what you would
do is like you would map whatever you
try to learn the raw observations into
some latent space. And that's where you
actually construct the graph. You
construct the graph in the latent space
rather than kind of in the raw space.
So that might be kind of a way to deal
with fuzziness as well. Right? Because
then I guess you might lose some of
these kind of very concrete one to one
mappings because you might learn some
node in the latent space that maybe
corresponds to three or four concepts
kind of mixed together. There's all
these kind of nice experiments with
neurons in deep networks, kind of
visualized, and they learn maybe kind of
a mixture of concepts. If you see what
actually activates that neuron is
actually maybe a few classes or
different kinds of things. It's not
necessarily a single thing. So it could
be something very similar here where you
have some very entangled representations
that are kind of distilled in this
latent graph. And then in a way, at
least in concept space, even if in the
latent space, that's still kind of a
very clear combinatorial structure
with respect to kind of your raw
observations.
That structure can still kind of encode
the fuzziness of the world to some
degree because you have this kind of
mixture of concepts that got distilled
in the same node or things like that.
Or maybe some concepts could be
represented by multiple nodes depending
on what way you see these concepts.
There might be all sorts of variations
or concept or points of view and so on.
So I think kind of latent graph
inference could be quite an interesting
way maybe to address some of these
issues we were discussing. Although I
think it kind of died off a bit in the
recent year, at least as far as I've
seen. There were a few slightly fewer
papers on the topic.
Well, certainly the agent's proposed
latent structure of the world, the
causal structure of the world is just
mapped on the territory and so it
enables maybe some of those core
screenings. Could you go to the slide
where there was a mapping between a
smooth sphere and then a regular
geometric shape?
Yeah, let's see in
this one. Yeah, just wanted to make one
point and see if you had any comments.
At the heart of some of the
relationships that you're describing and
where you pulled back to in terms of
generalization helps us understand this
relationship between the sphere and the
geometry and the implications
for data processing and all of the
computational science areas is if you
are preserving or learning or analyzing
geometry but not topology or the other
way around, you might get these
different data set. Aberrations. Like
you might have the topology of the
coffee cup, but it looks like something
totally different. And so what we would
really want to do would be understand
the relationship between geometry and
topology. Because if we could understand
it in principle, like you have it on the
left side and then in practice with the
data scheme on the right side or insert
your own left and right side there,
then we'd be able to do data analysis
in a way that respected preserved both
the topology and the geometry. So it's
like two compatible perspectives that
have their different strengths and
weaknesses and heuristics and so
understanding that relationship between
geometry and topology and
the implicit spaces that geometry
requires and so on, that has tremendous
use. And it just in closing, reminds me
of Buckminster Fuller's Synergetics,
which uses a close packing architecture
and a tetrahedron centric model of
coordinates to find more continuity
between surface area and volume and
between the smooth surfaces and the
great circles on them and like the
points of connectivity on shapes. So I
think it's an incredibly deep area and
really has fundamental impact in active
inference. Helps us think about our
models in this way, kind of like the
inflated balloon with the fuzziness and
the architecture and the finiteness.
It really brings a lot to active
inference. And so I appreciate you
sharing the work with us today and
continuing to work in this way.
Thanks a lot. Any last thoughts?
Yeah, what you mentioned,
I think it's been all over my thesis
this. Kind of tension between topology
and geometry. And maybe what I want to
emphasize is that I'm not saying kind of
the previous perspective of looking
maybe more geometrically at things was
wrong in any way. And on the contrary,
actually, there's lots of interesting
places where these things intersect.
Even in kind of this chief paper I
briefly went through, like, if you
actually read the paper, there's a lot
of beautiful intersections. Actually,
my main collaborator, Francesco, he's a
differential geometry, so he actually
had lots of kind of inputs from that
side. And indeed, I think we should
try to use all these kind of layers of
structure are in the best way possible
for all our methods. Awesome.
All right, thank you. Till next time.
Thanks a lot. Thanks for having me.